thanks for coming and thank you
pie de de la for having me my name is
Nick Acosta and I'm a developer advocate
with IBM data science community and
today I wanted to talk about IBM codon
response and that is our project that is
trying to address natural disaster
preparedness and relief through open
source so if there are any here that are
local to Los Angeles or to California
you know that it has been an
extraordinary past couple of years for
instance in this year alone there have
been almost 7,000 wildfires in the state
of California alone including this is an
image of the getti wildfires that just
ended about a month ago today on maybe
10 miles away from where we are now in
around the Malibu area of Los Angeles
they burnt around a thousand acres of
land destroyed 12 homes I mean again was
just one of around 7,000 wildfires this
year even worse was last year 2018 was
the most destructive and deadly year for
wildfires in California
ever there are over 8,500 different
wildfires in 2018
that burned 1.9 or so million acres of
land in California I'm and unfortunately
killed 99 people last year including
this is the woolsley fire that just
happened on the in the San Fernando
Valley of Los Angeles and there was a
camp fire in Northern California as well
that was the deadliest and most
destructive fire ever in California
history all right and this isn't just a
local issue unfortunately to Los Angeles
or to California but a national issue as
well so
you can see here 17 million acres have
been lost to wildfire in the United
States alone in the past two years so
it's a very much a national problem and
a global problem as well with over
800,000 deaths attributed to earthquakes
just this decade alone so natural
disasters are certainly among the
world's greatest challenges and you know
that is only becoming more and more
frequent and more and more devastating
right so I'm not only in financial loss
like the campfire that I just referenced
was the most expensive natural disaster
last year in terms of like reclaimed
insurance money but also you know and
much more importantly in terms of of
lives that we're losing to natural
disasters and the scale I think is
certainly too big for someone to take on
alone or for one company to take on
alone
but I do think that we can take some of
the innovations that we've seen in the
tech industry we're really providing
innovations and changing a lot of
different fields I think that we can
prove apply some of that same sort of
technology and innovation to this area
of natural disasters right and that's
what iBM is trying to do just community
wide within the open-source community
with IBM Cohn responds so IBM Cohn
response our aim is to inspire and
enable developers to create innovative
solutions to reduce the impact of
natural disasters so together IBM and
our partners are going to deploy these
solutions and communities which need
them the most
always shining a light on the heroic
work of saving lives around the world
through technology and volunteering and
that's what I'm going to be talking
about for the next 30 minutes or so so
we have an agenda for what I'll be going
over today touched on some of the
wildfires that we're experiencing and
have experienced here in California
before introducing call for code in
response in part to shortly I'll be
talking about call for code what that is
it's a project a annual project that IBM
has been working on with some partners
so some of the things that we've been
doing in the past two years
with that before talking about some
other initiatives in call for encoding
response I'll be discussing pythons
impact on these programs before wrapping
up so call for code call for code is a
worldwide developer Technol
technology solutions for natural
disaster preparedness response and
recovery so if you can see here iBM is a
founding partner of call for code but it
is very much a collaborative effort with
a number of different partners that you
can see here including the United
Nations and the American Red Cross you
can see here to the right some of the
price structure that we have for this
worldwide developer competition you know
there are cash prizes involved for the
winners and finalists but again through
a cone response one of our main goals is
to deploy these solutions and get them
in the hands of those that need help so
you can see some of our prize structure
is aligned to support that we have the
ability to open source projects through
the Linux Foundation and receive support
from the Linux Foundation in its open
source community and provide things like
solution implementation support which
all touch on here in a later slide so
call for 2018 was our first year for
colfra code and we had a project owl
were the winners of our first call for
code competition and their project keeps
first responders and victims connected
in a natural disaster so we had one
winner in 2018 but there are over a
hundred thousand different participants
developers building over 25 or 2,500
applications that were representative of
156 different nations participating in
this competition that was running from
March through October I mean you can see
some of the technologies that project I
will be used here so what their project
is
it is a two-part like software and
hardware solution where they are using
an incident management system here where
you can see that they are using
something that's fast and simple to be
able to identify and respond to
incidents in the presence of a natural
disaster and I think an innovative part
of their solution was their hardware
component this cluster doc-mobile
network that would be able to quickly
stand up an ad hoc Wi-Fi network service
through the use of IOT to mesh devices
where they could quickly deploy some of
these devices and stand up a mesh
network that could span you know a
number of square miles even and they
were resilient they're resilient devices
that can even you know be deployed in
the presence of a natural disaster so
this was a project developed by some
American developers for in response to
Hurricane Maria that happened in Puerto
Rico and 2017 but it certainly wasn't a
you know an American competition there
were finalists representing really all
points of our planet we had five
finalists in 2018 and you can see some
of them in their representative
countries listed here and I also wanted
to point out here at PI data so there is
the number of technologies involved
including you can see many of them
reference IBM Watson studio which if you
are familiar with like a jupiter
notebook environment that's just ibm's
implementation of like a hosted jupiter
notebook environment and some associated
services so some of these projects are
relying heavily on Python to produce
work to help others in October we just
finished our second iteration of call
for code and we had a group of
developers health professionals and
firefighters build out a solution called
pro matteo and pro matteo protects the
health of firefighters and first
responders with individual wearable
devices and we're also able to see in
our second year we almost doubled the
number of
developers that were involved and
doubled the number of applications built
so it's been cool to see that growth
just in a short amount of time with call
for code and call for code 2018 or
prompt was to challenge developers to
build technologies for natural disaster
recovery and preparedness in 2019 it was
to help alleviate some of the health and
wellness concerns that can arise in the
presence of natural disasters so what
Pro Mateo is doing is a wearable which
you can see a prototype of the wearable
in the top right here of my screen and
it collects basic telemetry of
firefighters which is sent to an IOT
platform to collect that information
information such as the temperature
humidity the presence of smoke and other
gases that could adversely affect these
firefighters and then Celyn that not
only to a machine-learning service i
could assess the risk and whether or not
you you know a fire fire made need to
evacuate his current area but also to a
dashboard for monitoring being here in
los angeles i also wanted to point out
just as in 2018 we had fine five
finalists and 2009 there are five
finalists as well including the Rove
team that you can see here that enable
emergency responders to reach victims in
the shortest amount of time and this was
a project that I wanted to highlight
because this was done by Daniel max
Brian and Lucas who are all CS
undergraduate students at UCLA just
close by in Brentwood so these are
students that were developed this
solution and became finalists I think
that they were the second runner-up this
year for call for code 2019 and because
of the work that they were able to build
out through call for code they actually
ended up creating and running a
student-led organization at UCLA called
Nova whose
whose goals are to build out software to
tackle you know problems in write
software so for social good
so it was cool to see them not only
build a solution but try to spread try
to spread what they've been doing across
campus um so that's been the first two
years briefly of call for code which is
it a component that code in response has
been running with a large help of you
know some of our partners I wanted to
touch on quickly on IBM code in response
as well before I do does anyone have any
questions about call for code maybe I
can quickly take one and we can have
some more questions at the end if
anything comes up but again our goals
for IBM Cardon response are to and
inspire and enable developers to create
solutions to induce the impact reduce
the impact of natural disasters so if
you have a technology or an idea for a
technology that could help others but
maybe some barrier to getting in the
hands of those that it can help an IBM
can help remove those barriers
IBM Cone response is the way that we are
planning to do so right so the
difference between you know having an
idea that can help others and actually
helping others can be maybe one resource
or one contact that you may be able to
make a need or even just like a cloud
database that you you know maybe your
resource strapped and need help with
that
you know and we want to be able to
provide those resources because it can
be a small difference between an idea
that can help people and actually
helping people and it can be just a
small of a difference between or just as
big of an impact you know in saving
lives with some of this technologies
that we're seeing here through coding
response so I touched on call for code
but there are a number of other
initiatives that we are doing under this
code in response umbrella this whole
process
is built from the top up with open
source in mind right so it's open up the
core and we're providing access to maybe
some of the more resource intensive open
source projects so if you have an idea
for a solution that maybe requires a
blockchain fabric we can have hyper
ledger or a you know container manager
we can provide access to kubernetes and
hype religion some of those other you
know open source projects that maybe
take a little bit of work to get off the
ground and all the code stays open right
so all the code that's prepared through
IBM code and response initiatives has an
Apache 2 license and is deployed with
open governance models and that can be
scaled through open governance so as I
mentioned at the beginning natural
disasters are a very global problem and
to address them we need a just an
equally as global of a method to begin
to tackle these problems and in
technology in 2019 that means it
definitely means through open source
it's the only way that you know I think
that this sort of work can be done if
you are familiar with github state of
the octave verse they stated that here
in 2019 of the open source projects I
have over a hundred different committers
that are hosted on github they are
represented on average by 41 different
countries all working together on these
open source projects which is a huge
number
right 41 different kind of countries on
average building out these technologies
not only is that a huge number it's a
very big it's seen a tremendous amount
of growth in the recent years so
definitely a very global community now
the open source software community and I
think that it can be very effective and
addressing some of these concerns like
natural disasters so the 2018 call for
code winner project owl began test
implementations do IBM code in response
just this March so you can see that they
started field tests in Puerto Rico
that focus on the deployment of their
clustered duct iot networks of these
devices that could stand up a Wi-Fi
network when that goes down because of
say a hurricane or other natural
disaster so they were able to set up
these mesh networks access them via
mobile phones and begin to transmit data
and send them to this incident
management software system so project I
worked through IBM code in response with
not only the IBM corporate service core
but some of our contacts with local
government officials in the University
of Puerto Rico as well if you would like
to get an update there was just some
more testing that they had done I think
maybe last month their github page is
linked here and I'll be sharing a link
to my slides at the end and all of the
projects that I've referenced
specifically all have hyperlinks to
their github repositories as well so if
there's something that has caught in
your interest all of these projects are
open-source and you can help get them to
a state where they are helping others
with these technologies right and I
think that that's as important as ever
especially for this project our solution
because it's been 2 years since
Hurricane Maria but Puerto Rico still
facing many issues you can see here that
there are two articles from the New York
Times one came out last year in
September on the first year anniversary
of Hurricane Maria on Hurricane Maria
anniversary Puerto Rico is still in
ruins and then just a couple weeks ago
Hurricane Maria two years later we want
another Puerto Rico so in this article
that just came out recently they were
saying that there was still over 30,000
different homes in Puerto Rico that are
partially or totally covered their Roos
are partially totally covered with blue
tarps because their roofs are failed or
broken or leaking or all of the above
right so still definitely need all the
help that they can get so I'm happy that
this you know technologies like project
owl are being worked on to be deployed
and in the hands of those living in
Puerto Rico that need help another
project that IBM is
working on that actually also came from
Puerto Rico I'm is drone aid so drone
aid uses a symbolic language that was
developed by the United Nations and in
the presence of a natural disaster the
idea is that drone aid will take drones
and be able to run object detection zhan
these symbolic languages and be able to
recognize when these when a drone sees
these labels and it will be able to plot
where these locations are in a map and
initiate a response so you can see that
there's a language here like this is a
symbol that means that there's water
needed in this area of food needed in
this area and this was developed a
codeathon that we prepared to help
produce solutions for call for code and
was just recently a couple months ago
picked up by an open source via the
Linux Foundation and you can find more
information on drone aid at its github
as well so speaking at CSULA I wanted to
quickly touch on the Clinton Global
Initiative and the Clinton in the CGI u
programs so IBM code in response has a
partnership with CGI u where we are
hosting ten codeathon that will engage
and inspire on college developers to
build technologies that are modern and
using open-source technologies to
develop solutions for natural disaster
response in resilience challenges so
some of these codons have already been
run a su ETH Zurich miami-dade RPI UC
Berkeley and UCSD I have a picture here
of the winners of the UC Berkeley
codeathon and I wanted to reference them
specifically because not only did they
win a coda phone and get a cash prize
through that event but they developed
their solution it's called project aster
they developed their solution entered it
into call for code and we're a finalist
this year for call for code as well so
kind of won twice with that project and
it's been cool to see that project
develop their github is linked on this
picture as well
the CGI you CGI and CGI you have deep
groups here in Los Angeles that I wanted
to quickly touch on Bill Clinton
actually announced in 2006 what would
end up becoming the Clinton Global
Initiative at UCLA is where it was first
announced and it became the CGI year
later here at CSULA they hosted a
codeathon with CGI you to help I think
it was to help alleviate heart disease
and women I think was what their
hackathon was based on and that was four
years ago so it'd be great to see some
more participants and you know maybe we
could have another codeathon here would
be great and then cg a CSU Northridge
that's just in Northridge on that in the
valley is a CGI u university partner
right so pretty deep roots here in Los
Angeles if you're an educator in the
audience and you're interested in
partnering with IBM Cohn response in CGI
you I would love to speak I quickly
wanted to discuss the role that Python
has been playing here at PI data open
with IBM code in response so you can see
here on the right github state of the
octave verse where they ranked the top
programming languages and their
appearance on github and just this year
Python became past Java to become the
second most popular programming language
on github which is awesome and you can
see that that's reflected in call for
code samples as well so I just took a
random sample of a hundred different
projects on github that reference call
for code and of those 100 projects 40 of
them were using Python and of some sort
and I don't know to my knowledge github
hasn't released how much more popular
Python is than Java now I don't know the
ratio of these just their ranking but it
was cool to see that Python is used
twice as often as Java in these call for
code projects
and again it was used by the 2018 winner
Project Dowell it was used by a number
of finalists including those finalists
that I mentioned from UC Berkeley and
UCLA so to review IBM code and response
is an initiative through IBM to help
inspire and enable developers to build
technologies that help aid in relief
natural disasters one of the components
the IBM is putting on together with
current responses call for code which is
a global competition that we are putting
together with a large number of partners
in march around the March timeframe we
will be starting our third year of call
for code so we are will be in the third
year of at least a five-year commitment
so I'm looking forward to color-code
2020 2021 and hopefully many years after
right so if you're interested in
participating I think that that prompt
will be coming out soon our challenge
and if you're interested in partnering
you saw the large partnership ecosystem
that we have it's not just IBM it's
United Nations American Red Cross the
Linux Foundation things like that I
would love to I would love to speak and
maybe we can get a partnership together
as well so there's participation
opportunities you saw some of that prize
structure I imagine that'll be very
similar next year and you saw our
partnership ecosystem as well so with
that I wanted to I thank you all for
attending again my name is Nick Acosta
and Thank You pied-a-terre life for
having me
so I can quickly I think we actually it
doesn't how much time do we have
okay so does anyone have any questions
thank you for the talk so I work in
conservation scape and we have like
plenty plenty of other organizations
that do something similar for example
Conservation X labs and what I have I
mean I've been thinking about it these
programs are really great but what
happens is solutions exist to the
problems that get defined but when it is
when it comes when the question of
production to the scale comes up that
doesn't happen because that might not be
even the objective of what you're doing
or what everybody else is doing so it
kind of like yeah we define the problem
or problem existed solution exists but
then that's it so does IBM or your
project has any goals taking it to scale
yeah so the question was there a number
of maybe similar incentive structures
right that not only IBM and our partners
are putting on together but some others
and it can often come that problem gets
identified but then you know technology
doesn't really built to fully be
deployed and be able to address that
problem and first I would like to
address and acknowledge that yeah I BM
isn't the only option if you have some
an idea for technology to help others
there are many different contests that
you know other organizations
organizations both large as big as you
know some of the other cloud service
providers are doing similar things there
are some smaller organizations there's a
lot of different avenues if you have an
idea to help others to get support but
what I like about IBM's that I'm seeing
is I think is unique is that price
structure that we have over not on just
giving money but also on deployment
services right so
you will get access to like IBM Service
Corps who have experience implementing
and consulting to be able to build out
these solutions and I think that another
thing that you mentioned she also
mentioned that there are some may be
problems or solutions that get repeated
I think that that's where open-source
comes in I'm very heavily right and the
mandating that all of these be open
hopefully we'll see others and we have
seen others contribute and add on top of
solutions other than rebuild them we've
actually seen in 2019 we saw there were
some contestants that submitted to call
for code 2019 that took the winner from
2018 project owl they took their project
and tried to add on top of it right and
then just really like resubmitted it and
that's you know exactly what we're
trying to see right so I think to answer
your question you know to reduce that do
duplicate bility is open source I think
for sure keeping everything open and
then yeah I mean just being aware and
keeping in mind that identifying a
problem is definitely step zero right
and we need to be able to work just as
hard to not only give out prize money to
incentivize identification of these
problems but have steps to actually
build technology and get them in the
hands of others and I hope and it's been
like a big goal of IBM's that we're
doing doing just that actually the
question what resources are available
towards the developers that are in the
like competition yeah yeah so we do have
a number of you know stipulations that
we saw as far as keeping your code open
and things like that I think that
there's another rule that I think
everyone maybe has to be over 18 we have
an FAQ page a call for code org I mean
you can get more information on code and
response that code and response org but
yeah there are not only some
requirements but some things that we
that we will provide access to
as well I mean helping getting these
solutions maybe some resources that you
may need as far as I compute services
and things like that all right let's
give a round of applause again for Nick
for his presentation thank you
[Applause]